renaud muselier merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation en direct sur rt france
alors pour commencer un mot sur la
visite d' emmanuel macron au liban son
avion vient tout juste d'atterrir c'est
la deuxième visite en un mois avec une
forte volonté diplomatique de faire
bouger les lignes là bas au liban en
pleine rentrée gouvernementale en france
avec des dossiers sensibles à gérer
alors est ce qu'il est dans son rôle le
président français il est pleinement
dans son rôle
on a eu une saute dans les différents
présidents de la république qui au fil
des ans reçoit le président chirac le
président sarkozy même le président
hollande bien sûr le présent mitterrand
travailler la main dans la main avec les
chefs d'état aujourd'hui au lendemain de
ce désastre
cette catastrophe qui montre la
difficulté du fonctionnement du pays le
président mâcon est allé tout de suite
là bas sur zone
je ne sais pas en tournée cette fois ci
vers les dirigeants mais vers le peuple
en dix ans maintenant je reviendrai le
1er septembre et il faut modifier votre
dispositif politique qui est très
complexe au liban est aujourd'hui
incontestablement il arrive à nouveau
premier ministre et nouer avec un
consensus politique pour la gestion de
cette crise est-ce que ce sera suffisant
c'est à voir en tout cas il ya eu pour
une fois une modification de la
gouvernance au sein des gouvernements
libres alors renaud muselier alors qu'on
voit en direct un ces images le
président michel aoun qui attend donc le
président français emmanuel macron
emmanuel macron qui s'est exprimé
vendredi la lys si nous lâchons le liban
ce sera la guerre civile at il prévenu
est ce que vous rejoignez ses propos au
bien de la guerre civile le liban et est
une son territoire a mis la france
francophone très important qui a réussi
à gérer un équilibre politique sur
incroyable que ce les libanais sont
capables de faire mieux aujourd'hui il
est au bord de l'implosion et donc au
delà de la guerre civile c'est son désir
année à côté les palestiniens de l'autre
israéliens et turcs devaient des forces
extérieures très puissante avec bien sûr
les grandes nations qui sont deuxième
volet et ça serait dramatique pour la
paix sur la méditerranée pour un
équilibre politique que le liban implose
à cause de tout c'est le problème
politique qui perdure au fil du temps il
ya le volet religieux qu'elle voulait
constitutionnel via le volet politique
est le volet financier et tout ça mis
bout à bout rend ce pays très
difficilement ou la main alors le
président mm macro 1 qui a insisté pour
un changement du gouvernement pour la
mise en place de réformes dans le liban
au nom de l'amitié franco-libanaise on
ne parle pas d'ingérence au nom de
l'amitié on parle de soutien savez on a
envoyé avec les régions de france près
de 2 millions d'euros on sait tous
mobilisés je présente des régions de
france
on a envoyé de marseille un bateau
affrété par cma-cgm avec les très
grosses entreprises pour le haut pour
l'aide alimentaire pour les deux
techniques pour les deux figures les
marins pompiers etc qui font en sorte
que l'on ait ce que ce pays est en
déliquescence
avant ce désastre sur le port qui est le
fruit d'une nourrice gouvernement soit
une absence de suivi
il y avait une crise financière majeure
une crise financière majeure ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que quand vous
êtes dans une banque où vous ne pouvez
sentir que 150 euros par mois
et bien que l'interdiction de sortir
plus et ça c'est très très compliqué
interne ce pays où l'addition de toutes
ces complexités de toutes ces
difficultés de toutes ces pressions
extérieures de tous ces drames
intérieurs avec un des routes qui a été
aux fabriques et on se rend bien compte
que la gouvernance était nécessaire
d'être changées est-ce que ça suffira
j'en sais rien mais en tout cas je pense
que là la france fait son rôle d'ami
voilà on voit ces images en direct un le
président emmanuel macron qui va sortir
d'ici peu de son avion une dernière
question à propos du liban qu'est ce que
vous attendez de cette visite de 24
heures diplomatique
j'attends que le président de la
république soutenue par les nations
unies puisse faire en sorte que le libor
ne soit plus
le lieu de toutes les 2 to de toutes les
turpitudes et est-ce qu'il va y arriver
il faut le souhaiter pour notre pays à
nous tous
renaud muselier je vous propose
d'attendre revenir à l'actualité
ici en france et donc la retrait la
rentrée demain dans une atmosphère de
crise sanitaire il y à des enseignants
qui sont inquiets il ya aussi des
médecins
vous êtes médecin des médecins qui ont
signé ce week-end dans une tribune dans
le parisien dénonçant un protocole
sanitaire trop léger mise en place par
l'éducation nationale
est ce que cette veille de rentrée en
tant que président de région vous êtes
inquiet longtemps que médecin je
n'aurais pas signé cette déclaration je
pense qu'on a la nécessité de s'adapter
à ce qu vide et faire en sorte que l'on
retrouve la vie différente mais avec nos
libertés mais liberté qui s'adapte à ce
problème de santé publique majeur
pourquoi c'est un problème sans type
humain je veux bien l'exemple de la
région commencent à choisir tout
particulier à marseille on a aujourd'hui
dans le cadre de l'incidence de la
transmission vous savez que ça ne
citerai à vos plantes
on a 100 77 pour cent mille habitants
alors que la france et assure son tennis
à peu près mais on a eu depuis mois de
joie un seul mort de 85 en réanimation
et une seule personne hospitalisée en
réanimation à youtube et ventilés
c'était en fait on est face à une
progression réelle mais en maintenant
une absence totale de mort donc il faut
raison garder et ne pas en permanence
tout rendre alarmiste étrangement alors
il faut raison garder est-ce qu'on
imposant le masque par tous y compris
pour les élèves dans les collèges à
partir de 11 ans est ce que c'est une
bonne chose selon vous je suis plus
réservé sur le traitement des crises
sanitaires j'avais émis toutes ces
réserves d'ailleurs dans le pic de
février mars où on est mon côté médecins
urgentistes fait en sorte que
spontanément j'ai pas envie de créer de
polémique dans des décisions politiques
qui essaye de répondre à une crise
sanitaire qui est incontrôlée on se
retrouve aujourd'hui avec effort de ce
nom masqué tout le monde et y est arrêté
il fallait surtout de permettre de
masquer justement comment vous comprenez
qu'est ce qui s'est passé finalement en
quelques mois pour passer du le masque
n'est pas nécessaire à aujourd'hui il
est indispensable partout même dans la
rue je pense que scientifiquement
parlant médicalement parlant quand de la
culture que l'on a maintenant sur le
retour comme ce soit en chine que ce
soit aux états unis que ce soit sur les
pays qui ont donné dès souvent nous on
se retrouve dans une situation où de
toute façon se laver les mains est
essentiel est resté à distance aussi et
le masque en vase clos et est
essentielle alors est il des jusqu'au
boutistes qui pensent qu'il faut que ce
soit les mettre dans l'espace public
moi j'entends tout cas d'argent pendant
sa côte d'azur on a acheté 14 millions
de masques comme personne en avait on
les a fait venir on a équipé nos
personnels de santé nos entreprises nous
lie c'est à nos abonnés et on a
aujourd'hui pour chacun de nos lycéens
c'est à près de 200 milles qui sont qui
vont entrer des masques lavables 35 fois
aide toi le ciel t'aidera fixe ou
taurine doctrine c'est ce que nous avons
fait ici en se disant que la vie doit
continuer quoi qu'il arrive alors cette
crise du conte ville elle a aussi des
répercussions économiques le pib a chuté
de près de 14% au deuxième trimestre
vous êtes inquiet pour les prochains
mois je trouve que dans autant que je
peux mettre des jugements mais c'est
tout ça c'est derrière sur les
sanitaires autant je trouve que ce qui a
été fait sur l'autorité de monsieur
bruno le maire
l'ancien gouvernement sur la crise
économique a été plus tôt bp
tout bien fait parce que il ya eu de
l'aide sur les filières et de l'est
trois entreprises aient une vision sur
la réindustrialisation nous mêmes en
nous devons hulot tant que président de
région la capacité d'intervenir dans
toutes nos régions puisque c'est dans
domaine de compétence avec l'économie on
a apporté des fonds convient de
résistance ont amené trésorerie on a
essayé de sauver l'entreprise en tout
cas est de sauver les emplois
pour autant bien entendu ceux qui
étaient en très grande difficulté pour
ne pourra pas les sauver je crains dans
le cas d'une semi confinement en fait
imposée par le gouvernement une nouvelle
crise potentiel économique et j'attends
avec impatience le contrat de plan de
relance du pronom miss monsieur castex
qui est incontestable en sera différent
et qui j'espère se racontent les
difficultés des entreprises dont
notamment
à présent j'ai pas réellement à ça c'est
ce que m'arrive pas bien mesuré c'est
que si cette crise économique n'est pas
bien traité
on en rate immédiatement une
répercussion avec une crise sociale est
là alors là c'est la denture dans un
pays qui souffre et qui est en très
grande difficulté sociale on parle
également beaucoup des violences ces
derniers jours un regard de la violence
dans notre société vous le comprenez
comment je vais jamais à venir jamais
admis la violence je suis dans la
culture du respect respect de moi mais
avec ce que j'ai à dire présenter nos
respects la république le respect des
règles des droits et le respect de
l'autorité et on est dans un pays qui a
perdu beaucoup en respect de l'autorité
donc tout ce qui représente une autorité
que ce soit un médecin un professeur un
policier un gendarme et un pompier
représente quelque part une tribu
adverse et donc je fais là dessus très
attentif aux couples police justice
parce que je pense que la justice doit
être rendue de façon immédiate sans
concession pour tous ceux qui font des
atteintes à la liberté et d atteinte à
la république des atteintes à anoblir
façon tout à fait stupide et b s'il et
ceci sans sens ans en position derrière
et donc la république elle doit on sait
une indivisible
avec la justice justice se doit de
passer vite et bien pour conclure renaud
muselier une question un peu plus
politique
ce week-end c'était la rentrée des
républicains à la baule les potentiels
candidats pour représenter votre parti à
la prochaine présidentielle vont
progressivement se déclarer une annonce
très attendue celle de françois baroin
notamment est ce qu'il ya une figure qui
se détache aujourd'hui selon vous pour
incarner les valeurs des républicains et
en même temps pour offrir une véritable
alternative à emmanuel macron en tout
cas notre formation politique existe la
rentrée officielle finalement piloté par
l air aura lieu ce week-end et j'y serai
bien entendu sa cote est de paris koffi
le mans et des mesures de précaution
indispensable
nous avons notre 50 ans de genre et de
candidats potentiels se prouve que la
vivacité il ya de la vie
différence pour moi je suis pas dans la
guerre des personnes je suis pas non
plus d'en savoir exactement dans le
cadre du programme qui pour qui kiffent
pourquoi on est dans une sensibilité
politique de la droite et du centre qui
se doit d'être organisés et si on est
très bien organisée sur le plan
territorial
on a un manque d'incarnation au niveau
national christian jacob et en le
ciblant de tout ça il le fait avec grand
talent je dirais que plus tôt plutôt de
savoir qui est capable d'y aller car est
pourquoi je préférerais qu'on décale
finalement d'abord je pense qu'il faut
pas de primaire moi je pense que c'est
pas la pmr je pense qu'à la peine
pourquoi pas de primaires parce que là
la fois on a fait une primaire ouverte
avait été remarquable assez exceptionnel
et d'autres candidats s'est écrasé en
plein vol en janvier donc c'est pas la
bonne formule
je pense qu'il faut attendre le mois de
mars et attendent mois de mars pour voir
comment ça se passe au niveau national
ne pas parasiter tous en même temps
dans le cadre de 2,7 de cette relance ou
choqué sur la crise économique et
sanitaire plus de cannes et sociale
plutôt et donc attendant de passer les
élections départementales et les
régionales pour voir s'il ya un candidat
chez nous qui se dégage et puis s'il est
à prix on trouvera le moyen de se
départager
merci beaucoup rené muselier d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes président de la région sud
provence alpes côte d'azur